we're going to begin with a global
outpouring of anger and shock over the
brutality of russia's war on ukraine
mass graves and bodies in the streets of
kiev the suburb of bucha tell a story of
indiscriminate murder many world leaders
are now calling it a war crime deborah
patch and her crew traveled to bucha to
see for themselves the evidence of
killings that russia claims it's not
responsible for deborah joins us now
from keiv deborah good morning to you
this is very tough to watch
good morning indeed russia has actually
denied killing unarmed civilians saying
the deaths occurred after they'd left
the area but newly released satellite
photos show bodies strewn across the
town long before russian troops bid a
hasty retreat
and when we visited butcher we saw
undeniable evidence of atrocities we
warn you these images are disturbing
this is what war crimes look like
defenseless civilians shot in the head
with their hands bound
residents taking their last ride
mass graves filled with the bodies of
nearly 300 executed people
this couple thought they'd recognize
their son's arm and one of them it was
not him their grim search continues
when we visited butcher we saw a trail
of destruction and death in a basement
we stumbled on the body of this man he
appears to have been blindfolded hands
tied behind his back the rudimentary
safety helmet he wears no defense
against a bullet to the head
yuri saw russian soldiers bring him here
they were taking him at gunpoint he told
us
russian troops set up camp in a
courtyard outside his apartment block
their presence still felt in the
discarded beer bottles empty munition
boxes and overturned cars on the first
day of the invasion russian paratroopers
spilled onto the tarmac at the nearby
airport this is what's left of hostimal
airport where one of the most
significant battles of this war was
fought preventing the russians from
taking it over
it's an apocalyptic vision the crumpled
melted frame of the world's largest
plane testament to the fierce fight that
stopped russian forces from setting up a
supply line here but it could not halt
their invasion of nearby butcher and the
horror that followed
tanya nederskevska found her dead
husband in a pile of bodies at the foot
of a basement staircase
i'm begging you to do something
make peace so no one ever grieves again
she sobs
everyone just wants to live
the tears of a widow demanding to be
heard
imploring the world not to look away
gail and i need to point out that i'm
really finding it hard to understand why
questions have even been raised about
the veracity of these terrible images
i've covered many conflict zones and
witnessed some of the most brutal
atrocities of this century and frankly
gail what i saw in butcher is among some
of the worst i've seen i personally saw
evidence of war crimes and these stories
can't be staged and the overwhelming
grief that i've witnessed that just
can't be manufactured
you know the thing that gets to me
deborah we we now say it so much about
these images may be disturbing this is
tough to watch we warn you i worry that
people get desensitized to it but you
see an image like that the shot of the
the person on the bicycle because we've
all ridden bicycles you see the person
on the bicycle you see the woman who was
crying about her husband we don't
understand the language but we certainly
understand the emotion of what that
woman was saying to us
[Music]
indeed and i think you know the the
issue here is that this is something we
can relate to by as you said seeing that
bicycle
yeah and in some ways we need to be
disturbed by these pictures
yep i agree with that too as tough as is
we have to tell this story deborah
potter we thank you we thank you thank
you